Ну що?
Куди йдемо?
Ти дивишся телевізор,
і от світ ззовні абсолютно не чекає людей
з якимись порушеннями здоров'я.
Там суцільні бар'єри тощо.
І ми завжди намагаємося показувати,
що є хорошого.
У першу чергу, на що
наша ініціатива спрямована,
це на зміну свідомості людей з інвалідністю
і сприйняття суспільства людей з інвалідністю.
Тому що є перекіс з обох боків.
Ми в «Доступно.UA» не акцентуємо увагу,
що доступність потрібна
людям на візках чи людям з інвалідністю.
Ми акцентуємо увагу на тому,
що це потрібно всім і кожному.
Здоров!
Привіт, привіт.
— Вітаю.
— Привіт.
Ну що, Дімо, готовий?
Вивчив усі питання?
— Так.
— [сміється] Так?
Так, ну що?
Що ми робимо?
— Давай, скручуємося. Де твоє майно?
— Так, скручуємося.
Оцим всім [затягуй],
і воно зафіксується.
— Ти знаєш, так?
— [російською] Звичайно.
Так прикольно.
Щоб ти бачив, так?
Ну, ти пам'ятаєш свої питання, так?
— Чи давай трошки повторимо?
— Ні, я...Треба повторити.
Я на камеру зіграв,
що я пам'ятаю.
[сміються]
Ні, я пам'ятаю частину,
що таке пандус.
Усе починалось з ініціативи.
Хотілося бути в якийсь спосіб
корисним для суспільства,
і ми просто з подругою почали робити.
З Вітою в фейсбуку писати про заклади,
які є доступні чи недоступні.
Щоб люди з інвалідністю розуміли,
що є щось хороше,
все ж таки є кудись і сходити.
А, на противагу,
якщо заклади недоступні,
то привертати увагу власників
до того і давати рекомендації,
як це краще зробити.
Про нас почули, дізнались,
підтримали люди.
Причому підтримали більше
не люди з інвалідністю,
а просто жителі.
І що?
І як я з цим буду?
Ну от зараз подивимось.
Будеш як цей, Термінатор.
[сміються]
Бачиш, його треба затискати
так, нормально.
Добрий день!
Скажіть, будь ласка, ви добре
затиснули вашу штангу?
Ну, так собі.
[сміється]
Вмикай запис, і погнали.
Коротше, ми їдемо в Маріуполь
найближчої неділі.
У нас там мають бути представники
місцевого офісу наших донорів.
Вони мають прийти до нас на зустріч.
Є такий додаток — «Доступний Маріуполь»,
який хтось локально розробив,
там всі локації...
Вони теж мають бути в нас у гостях.
Паралельно йде Старобільськ.
Нам знову не дали спецкупе,
але дали три місця у звичайному купе.
По класиці.
За цей час нашої діяльності
в нас сформувались три такі напрямки.
Це тренд доступності,
тобто ми поширюємо через наліпку
«Доступно.UA рекомендує».
«Відкриті двері» нагорода в нас є.
Для найкращих практик доступності в Україні.
Для мене було важлива історія
от з картою доступності, додатком,
який зараз ми вже запустили
і працюємо над ним, розвиваємо.
Я розумів, що якийсь час
я просто не ходив в якісь заклади,
тому що я не знав,
що вони є доступними.
Інше — це нормалізація сприйняття
інвалідності в тому сенсі,
що люди, котрі мають
якісь порушення здоров'я,
не є героями чи не є жалюгідними,
потребують рівних можливостей.
Зараз я оп!
Ви ззаду просто ручки притримайте,
щоб я вперед не нахилився на колясці.
Тут.
Можна?
Давайте.
Оп! Є.
Гоп!
Третє — то мотивація до активного життя,
що найближче мені,
бо це найлегше.
Ти собі просто живеш
і мотивуєш людей.
Я подорожував автостопом
Україною і Білоруссю,
ми писали про це.
Потім Європою: поїхав з товаришем
за €100 на двох на місяць.
Ми каталися,
десять країн проїздили.
Привіт.
Перепрошую, можу кілька питань
поставити з приводу міста для людей,
і для кого це потрібно взагалі?
Блін, а можна не мене, я дурний?
[сміється]
Так нам цікава думка
пересічних громадян.
А знаєш, що таке пандус?
Ні.
А як ти думаєш,
що це може бути?
У мене в голову одне тільки приходить,
але я це говорити не буду.
[сміється]
Та ні, скажи, нам цікаво.
Та ні, я не скажу.
Ну, скажи.
[гигоче]
Перший виклик був —
це почати знімати відеоблог.
І виявилося, вони можуть бути корисні.
Ми розказали, запропонували читачам
(точніше, я розповів про свою травму),
і запропонували їм ставити
якісь питання, які їм цікаві, для того,
щоб ламати ці стереотипи в суспільстві,
розказувати, що і як відбувається,
як долати ті чи інші перешкоди.
А знаєте, що таке тактильна плитка?
Це, напевно, те, що намагаються
покласти в деяких місцях.
Намагаються? Дуже цікаво.
— Тактильна плитка — це жовта оця?
— Так, так.
[російською] А розкажіть нам про свій проєкт.
«Доступно.UA», «Школа Доступності».
Ми займаємось питаннями
якраз безбар'єрності, доступності,
ламаємо стереотипи,
робимо відеоблоги різні,
показуємо про те, як жити
і насолоджуватись життям попри те,
що в нас є така ситуація з доступністю.
Зараз ми нарешті заснували
Бюро доступності,
тому що зрозуміли,
що «а скільки можна все це
постійно безкоштовно робити?».
Тому що якби це...
Ну хоча би в соціальне підприємництво
перевести для того,
щоб забезпечувати діяльність
громадської організації.
Я бачу, що змінилось,
уже вказівник вказаний, де ліфт.
Раніше його не було.
Ну і там ще й воно продублюється,
тому що було складно
дізнатись про це,
що тут є ліфт.
Я певен, що більше клієнтів почало
користуватися цим ліфтом,
бо тепер знають,
що він тут є.
І, відповідно, це збільшує
прибуток навіть самої мережі,
оскільки люди можуть більше завантажити
і безпечніше його спустити на перший поверх.
У суспільстві є стереотипи:
«Це ж для людей з інвалідністю, це...
Та робіть це безкоштовно».
Коли ми почали надавати рекомендації
вже на платній основі,
ти чітко розумієш:
ти робиш це, і тут будуть зміни.
Бо люди, які платять, — вони,
отже, точно налаштовані на те, щоб змінювати.
І це ще приємніше,
тому що ти прямо бачиш результат.
Не думаєш, що можливо буде,
можливо не буде,
а знаєш, що це буде.
Добрий день!
Знаєте, що таке МГН?
Розшифруй.
А як, на вашу думку,
що це може бути?
— МГН?
— МГН, так!
А скажіть, знаєте,
що таке пандус?
— Знаємо.
— А що?
[нерозбірливо]
Ага, треба тоді до когось іншого.
А МГН?
Що це таке?
Не знаю.
До маломобільних груп населення
відносяться як люди літнього віку,
так і батьки з дитячими
візочками, маленькі діти,
ті, хто тимчасово мають
порушення здоров'я.
Та навіть з важкими валізами чи після тренування
люди радше скористаються ліфтом,
не будуть себе далі добивати.
І це й безпечніше, спокійніше,
аніж долатимуть бордюри.
Добрий день!
Перепрошую, можна вам поставити питання,
чи зручне місто вам?
— Добрий день.
Скажіть, як ви думаєте:
зручно пересуватися містом?
Містом?
Так-так.
Ви маєте на увазі Києвом?
Києвом, так.
Ну, мені здається,
що взагалі це місто не призначене
для маломобільних людей.
Класно, ви навіть знаєте такі слова!
А як батькам з дитячими візочками?
Я — тато з дитячим візочком,
і це — повний відстій.
По-перше, його треба майже
в будь-який час брати на руки.
Це взагалі незручно.
А потім, якщо навіть є пандус,
то хай би вони вбились на тому пандусі.
Це просто...
Ну, я знаю,
що ви бачили ці пандуси,
і на них просто треба
якийсь квест робити, челендж.
Наприклад, IronVizokMan
[залізний чоловік на візку].
Ми з командою чого хочемо,
щоб в Україні були рівні можливості,
у всіх були рівні можливості,
незалежно від рівня мобільності.
Це те якраз, що ми мотивуємо
людей до активного життя,
але не можемо відповідати за те,
що вони будуть реалізовувати
свої можливості.
Але для того, щоб кожен
мав рівні права,
треба і рівні можливості забезпечувати.
Все це, насправді, робить
людей щасливішими,
відповідно, вони можуть і продукувати
якісь ідеї для суспільства,
розвивати більше своє місто.
Мене особисто мотивує найбільше —
це зміна у свідомості людей.
Коли реконструювали цю зупинку,
повністю підняли її.
Тут були критичні кути нахилу,
я просто вилітав на дорогу з нього.
І після сюжету й допису на нашій сторінці
впродовж місяця це змінили.
От зробили вже зараз
у рівень з тротуаром.
Клас.
Саме соціальні ініціативи і рухають
нашу державу до якихось змін.
Тому що якби їх не було,
то все було б зовсім на іншому рівні.
І, особливо, саме після Революції
Гідності люди зрозуміли,
українці зрозуміли, що треба брати
все у свої руки і рухати це.
«Доступно.UA» загалом — це як
такий великий шмат мого життя,
реалізації от саме цього бажання —
надихати людей,
змінювати якесь сприйняття,
ставитися краще до життя,
і світу, і людей довкола.